like, so one thing i had a hard time even kind of getting a handle on
were the the stakes of this question, like why does the relationship between the series and the event
what what are the stakes of a question like that? it's obviously important to him
why why do we want to think it through in such detail? i can tackle the the event part of the
question which i'm sure you guys are familiar with and i'm probably not going to say anything
new about this but i mean this is written during the sort of height of structuralism in in france and
so the Levi-Strauss, Lacan examples are like the structuralist figures you know in in france at
the time structure sign in play the beginning of Derrida essay right something like an event has
happened in the history of structure except for that it's the whole purpose of structuralism to
reduce the event to a structure so that the the notion of the event is often opposed you know
structures are these systems that are in place and events are things things that happen think of long
and parole being the kind of paradigmatic examples uh with so so long being language as a structure as it
exists and then parole is actual what people say and write you know um so and this to me is you know
what defines if if you want to come up with like what defines poststructuralism to me has always been
an attempt to take to to problematize the dichotomy between long and parole or structure and event and
to think the of to think structures as constituted by nothing but events right which is to say structures
are themselves residual events and to me that's what makes you know that that's the break from or break but
that's the shift from like early to late Bart from you know um psychoanalysis of Lacan to someone like
Zizek or you know to i mean obviously folks like Deleuze, Derrida you know those folks are all thinkers
of the event in a sense of thinking the event's primacy in relationship to structure so structure is not
primary right structure is i mean in my terminology you just be saying structure is performative
right like i mean that's the for me that's the simplest way of understanding structures are enacted
they're not given right um and so to me that that's the reason for what he does with the event
particularly i mean there's one of the series where one of the later ones that we read that where
it's pretty explicit where he's like structures are made up of nothing but series of events right so i
think the term series is coming to replace the term structure um and and so the relationship between
this sort of close or ambiguous relationship between series and event those are the terms that he's
really kind of trying trying to work with in a non-dualistic uh way from that structure so
it strikes me as that's the kind of big overarching goal of of using that terminology that's my sense
anyway and each chapter is not a chapter but a series right so there's something formal right but a
series is constituted by differential relations with other series you know so there's not a series
right there's no such thing as one series in that sense a series seems to be just like a line of
thinking you could call it right like it's not a claim it's not a proposition it's not uh it isn't
a structure in the way that we think of like you know heteronormativity as a structure or patriarchy
as a structure or you know language as a you know it's it's not it doesn't seem to work like a structure
it's like i mean i i have to say like my sort of visual image of this is much more like you know if
you picture a structure to be it as i think of it like a it's like a Lincoln Log or Tinker Toys
actually is my image my mental image is this well like remember those spindles that had holes in
them and you stick like a structure you put a bunch of those together and you have a structure
right um a series doesn't work in those terms right a series is moving a series is uh you know
relational to its previous ones and to anticipatory of ones to come so to me i mean i just feel like
series is a way of thinking structure in a much more mobile yeah i mean i i was thinking about why
he uses the language of series because he often seems to you know the the term that that would come
more naturally to me or just like sets of relationships but i i think that he uses the
language of series simply because it invites thinking movement a whole lot more but it also allows him
to think like the repetition involved in any given series that makes it unequal to itself it allows him
to think becoming into a set of relations or becoming into a structure like what if structures are nothing
but uh uh never-ending becoming um and so like you know he's trying to think of a logic here of the
way that things cohere together but never sort of assemble into anything stable enough to um to determine
something else in a kind of general specific uh uh logic and to me i mean this is what really has
Been dawning on me reading these, these series is that they're this is really him thinking through
a flat plane of ontology where he's he's taking the the general specific um uh relationship that would
sort of, you know, like the long uh pearl uh relationship where you know the the language is is you know
that the general structure that provides then the conditions of possibility for acting out the events
of of speaking and he's flattening those out which is that events are structuring and structures are
nothing but the residue of of events and you know i really kind of wanted to set up a couple of
diagrams for this one um that you know that uh turning the idea of this because structures almost
always run vertically right. They almost always we only really ever think of them as you know the
governing rule and then the instance of the governing rule the general and the specific but when you turn
that horizontal um and then what you have are um intersecting lines or intersecting series that
accrue mass and and establish relationships and alliances with each other and you know create centers of
gravity or or you know more traction less surfaces of that that that that pickup speed well then what you
have is a a sense of structure that um uh that isn't operating from the top down but sort of like
from the center out and then it makes it so that it is capable of affecting anything that it comes into
contact with and it is affected by anything that comes into contact with it and its very own movement
this is where you have to struggle the inside outside relationship of the structure is that
its own movement as you know being nothing more than constituted by a whole bunch of other series
is constantly like as it struck as the structure structures itself it is constantly undergoing
its own self-undercoming right. So i think those two things is that that that flattening out the play the
ontological playing so that we're thinking about structures on a horizontal rather than vertical
matrix and then also thinking about the the movement or perpetual self-displacement of structures as
evolving series and it requires that um right the kind of exploration or or the the the refiguring of time
right right in a way that i mean so so so that's the the the emphasis of the question i i know the stakes
between structure and event but like series is not simply structure seems to me and and um right
but when you use series right it it does seem to require a kind of you know progression right which which
which is you know i liked those moments when he talked about thinking about time right. A total
rethinking of time that's not a chronological time yeah we're gonna get to i mean his term is not kairos
it's Aeon you know that becomes his term but for our purposes you might as well just say it's kairos right
that the the the time of the series is not linear and in in a chronos divisible sense i mean he says
something like that even in the passages that we talked about right like the the time is i think it's in
the second series and there i mean there is chronological time but i think chronological time
only takes place in the past and in the future and only refers to um to bodies right that you that you
know the sort of like in um infinitely um um subdividable time right um which is so that it's the domain of
of the name is the domain of of the noun um where you create where like the domain of structures right
the sort of the residues of of the in the moment becoming but the Aeon or the or kairos is always
the sort of like the the warped time that is only ever the present but it can never be the past or the
future but it's always simultaneously opened up to the past and the future it's it's it's warped in the
present right. It's a it's a ratio it's a differential it's he calls it the mad but coming in a few places
it's you know it's really interesting to think about this in terms of stake because i know we've
been kind of you know reading slightly arbitrarily like oh here's like 10 pages let's go and here
we're like oh five to ten or five to nine whatever whatever any of us read um but it really
struck me with this kind of unit um of series that the stakes seem to be more methodological than they
have felt in the past like with what we've already read it kind of felt like we were kind of teasing
out the methodological stakes and here it was like no no you can kind of develop series by doing this
right it was kind of like he was sharing and circulating exactly how to get to kind of the engine
of distribution like the at that engine of movement and i thought that was really interesting it was
like no no here's what happens when you take an esoteric word and put it in conjunction with this
series you get two new series or or not new but you get two other series right um and it was really
interesting to kind of think about how he was inviting us into the method i obviously haven't read
the Lewis Carroll because i mean there's like a another novel i guess and a short story that he
Referred to that I don't know anything about, but it's just interesting to think of a short story as
being read as deploying series and relations to them. I mean, it's just a different a different way of
conceptualizing the thought experiment of a short story or a novel, and you know, like, okay, so Lewis Carroll
in this short story puts two series together that are linked by a clock, right, that doesn't that has
eight hands and doesn't tell time, but time tells it. It's like, well, I can almost kind of construct in
my head what I imagine the short story was what was about, um, but I would never have thought to think
of it in terms of the connection of series around an odd, you know, a strange object or something like
that. Um, so it's just an interesting at least for me. Nothing if nothing else, it's just a sort of shift
in perspective as of a way of thinking of understanding, you know, what people do when they
write stories or make stories, you know? Yeah, again, I, I know I already mentioned that this feels
kind of like the stakes for Bart, but it really does feel like there's this shared kind of some French
thing happening where it just feels like they know that there's an order of the known and you, I mean,
yes, you have to work with the order of the known, but like that habit of thought is really it just feels
like that's the thing that's driving all of this. It's like we, we have this habit of thought and it's led
us to think about time in this way and it's led us to think about, you know, even thought in this way, but
we have to shift. Well it seems to me that this is very much so in keeping with the other stuff that
Deleuze is writing around this time especially Difference and Repetition, where you know, like
his fundamental claim is like look we're we have we have not thought of difference as anything other
than as as a than as a sort of like derivative or side effect of of the same, right, um, the difference
between two things and we haven't thought of of difference in its in its own right and you know this
whole book seems to be an attempt to we we talked about your structure, um, you know, like it's the
logic but it's the logic of sense and sense then becomes this this far more amorphous thing and it
seems to be the differential of of like how do you think structure order, um, uh, in relationship to
something very amorphous like sense but sense has this sort of very duplicitous role between the two
um, where it is both the um, you know, it it it exp sense is expressed, right, and then sense is also taken
up as as an object. I mean, this is the problem of the the um, of the infinite series, right, where any
the the knight's song, right, that you know, any given proposition is sort of um, governed by or expressed
expressed expresses a particular sense, but you can never talk about that that sense. You can only
is in taking up the sense of the proposition just uttered you're you're mobilizing a new sense and you're
re-mobilizing the sense that you're taking up while you're sort of hypostasizing, you know, this amorphous
thing. I I read that I I really liked the regress thing, um, and I I sort of read it I mean maybe this
is just because this is what we were talking about six weeks ago or whatever, um, but in terms of Hegel
like a response to Hegel's sort of like increasing levels of self-awareness so that you think a thought
then you think you become aware that you thought the thought then you become aware that you've become
aware that you thought the thought, right, um, and here you just have a displacement as opposed to it, uh, a
heighten a heightening of it, right, you just have a a series. I mean, you can say, you know, he calls it
infinite regress but it's not really regress it's just differential expansion or something else you
know, um, that you're not getting a heightened purchase at any point on anything you are simply, uh, you know
like it's just the next move on the chessboard when you when you talk earlier about the flattening out
that to me is an example of the flattening out is you know what the name is or what the song is is
just different than what the name is and then the difference in what is the name is called or what it is
called, you know, those are those are just different things, um, so and they all come from the song
right like apparently you know they all it's not like he's just making making things up but but that
sense that the the sense is the kind of you know and I understand in terms of the thinking of sense
like I get a lot of the dynamics the ontological dynamics that he's going with because you're right
he does use the example a lot here of the flat right like the flat mirror facing two sides or whatever
um, but you know that the sense is the sort of enabler of the proposition but it's never what
a proposition can talk about you need another proposition to talk about the sense of of the
first statement so that sense is always that which is enabling and never simply reducible to
you know pointing to, um, so I mean I I like the moves are familiar in that regard right like the the moves
are familiar in terms of continental thinking I get the moves, I get the sort of conceptual diagram
I still just don't really have a very good sense of what sense is, you know, or I have less of a sense of
what what the Logic of Sense, what do we mean? I mean what does it mean? And I'm not trying to
nail it down, but I just feel like I'm I'm not even ambiguous, right? Like if it was ambiguous
I'd feel like I'd have competing conflicting definitions that I was trying to struggle with
I don't have any I I feel like I have less of an uh of a sense of sense now than I did before we
started. Like I don't even know what he's talking about. I don't know, I don't know what we're talking
about either. It's like it's like those thought bubbles, you know, in cartoons where like the thought
bubbles go up and eventually make, you know, a space where there's meaning or something, but
instead it's just thought bubbles percolating all over the place, which actually makes a lot of sense
because once again once you try to capture or chase that sense into something like a flat mirror
he's literally proliferating more sense as he puts that into play, right? I mean that would be the
terminology that he would use, but I don't even know what it means to say that, right? Like I mean I I agree
with you, that's what I'm saying. It's weird because I kind of understand. I feel like I understand the
architecture kind of well, but I don't know what it's the architecture of. Like I don't understand
so so that's what I'm saying. Like when you say sense, you know, faces both sides, I'm like oh yeah, I'm
familiar with that kind of diagram that's trying to flatten things out. I mean I get that, I get the
architecture, but I don't know what what work sense does. Like so there are times where sense seems to
be a relay between a couple of different series. I get what that I get again I get the architecture
I mean I get the idea of a couple of different series that they're you know connections that are
getting made and we're going to call that sense, but I don't understand what we're I just don't have
really like a sense of what we're talking about. Like I don't have a a kind of beginner footing, right?
Like um for instance when he uses paradox like early on in the first few series it was way easier
for me because I kind of understood like uh paradox I can live with. I can live with the unresolvability
of it. I can live with I get that idea of like okay there's a direction here and there's a direction
here and they're, you know, incompatible or whatever else, but I don't know I don't know that I even have
any of anything like a vague inkling of what sense is and why we're even interested seem to be the
object of much of what's talked about in these series at all, right? Except for five
it's you know it's discussed as the difference between terms, right? It's like just that
so I mean like another way of saying it is, you know, the the banal recitation that I did, right, at
the beginning of structure and event and that sort of shit, like I kind of get the stakes of the notion
of the event. I kind of get the stakes of the notion of series, even series, even if I don't like fully
can't fully unpack it, but I just don't have any idea why we're talking about sense, what sense is trying
to do, why I mean I just I I feel kind of way more lost that because I mean it's actually because
Caddy like you were I mean just from the things that you said last time and then also some of the
text right like like you're like oh this notion of sense is doing work for you and thinking about
doxa and I was like please tell me what that means because I don't I mean really like because I just
don't feel like I have a any kind of a hook into it. It just is this it's it's it's like Jabberwocky
like it really is for me this kind of nonsense word that I'm really you know the nice thing about
Jabberwocky is I can treat it as a nonsense word and then try to see how the nonsense works, right, or
the it's not nonsense, you know, but whatever um like in the portmanteau words like in each of those cases
I can see what he's attempting to do um so there's some connection there but with sense I don't see
it. I'm just kind of like it's like this vacant space for me that I feel like I have no hook into
at all, you know. Sense, I think, creates a field of possibility, right, which is why that always has to
work in in multiple directions at once, and you know on page 33 this is in the um the fifth series
you know he he says um uh what does take quantity all men are white no man is white some men are white
or relation uh or relation sense must be the same in the case of the inverse uh inverse relations since
the relation with regard to sense is always established in both directions and at once in so
far as it causes all the paradoxes of becoming mad to appear yet again sense is always a double sense
and excludes the possibility that there may be a good sense in relation, right? And and so I mean to me
This is also another way of of um dealing with the problem of a structuralist orientation to language
that is anchored in some kind of like you know there is a general rule and then or the general
language and then it finds its reference it finds its um it finds its hooks into into reference and
which which doesn't allow for any kind of movement doesn't it only it becomes merely referential
and you get the problem of floating signifiers and mismatches between you know speech and and and
language and you know i i i think he's trying to suggest that for language to work at all you cannot just
associate arbitrary sounds with sort of pre-existing physical objects that you know a word is never
identical to a word that a word is the same the same word like the you know cup and cup are never
identical with each other until cup is put into a a series of of other words which establishes a logical
sense which establishes sort of like a field of possibility for which it's for for this thing the cup to operate
within what but it's always so that's the thing that would be like the signification what he was
calling the signification in that second series right that that this the necessity of being placed
into some sort of except for what i think he was talking about signification in the earlier series
he was thinking of that and he was thinking of it as a much more of a transcendent law that governs over
the thing right but i think this i think sense for him is much more imminently created which is why
it's a singularity rather than it has it has a singular relationship to the series rather than the
general specific relationship i mean so look at um series nine
sort of the beginning there where he's talking about i think singularity is another word for sense for him
and you know this is i mean i think it's very similar to the way that you and Deleuze use the word
a signification john like i mean there was a certain point where he's talking about signification
and i was like this would make so much more sense to me you know this is this is after he first introduced
signification in the more familiar sense and you know this is in um 40 on page 40 you know he starts
talking about signification quite a bit again like this would make so much more sense if he was just
talking about a signification where signification is putting series in communication with each other so
that like the a difference the differential redistributes the relationship of the both series at the same time
um so he's like you know this is on page 52 in the ninth series um after he's talking about
he gives all these sort of ways of thinking about what a singularity is you know they're turning
points points of inflection bottlenecks knots foyer centers blah blah blah it is essentially pre-individual
non-personal and a conceptual and and more importantly than anything else it is not ordinary it cannot you
cannot find it on you know you cannot find the coordinates of it on a taxicon a taxonomical
general specific map and at the bottom of 53 i i really like how he summarizes that idea when he talks
about the reversal of platonism it's that last line on page 53 to reverse platonism is first and
foremost to remove essences and to substitute events in their place as jets of singularity
and they're rather i mean i think this is why this is how he's moving away from that first sense of
of signification that he deals with that you know you can't talk about the logic that governs a general
specific um uh field and that that then fixes a reference um uh according to its essence right
um that will sort of like get to the inside of the thing but rather you have to think about the this
series is displacing itself on the flat plane that you know like because of the singular different
because of a singular differential point it it shoots out you know i i wrote line of flight underneath
that jet singularity they're just too too similar to each other to me to to not um but it it creates
you know it it creates a line of flight that has a a trajectory unique to the differential equation
whatever you want to call he talks about differential calculus quite a bit that flings it off in some
kind of direction that makes it more likely to intersect with other lines and from from certain
angles and it is likely to intersect with different lines with different angles and then form different
alliances with them form different singularities yeah okay so i mean i mean maybe i'm just feeling kind
of cranky today which is entirely possible um because i get that like i i get that um but i i mean i have
two kind of resistances in terms of the description that you just the the the text passages that you went to
there where and those are both moments for me that i like i underline but i was also like
um for instance pre-individual non-personal and a conceptual i had that like like again i get it from
other stuff that i've read in terms of that sense of singularity is pointing to the hesiety i like that
Term in Thousand Plateaus of, like, the thisness of something that's irreducible to its, its, um, um
um existence in a matrix of a general-particular dialectic, like, and so I, I, I have a sense of
what he's after there, but I'm just resolutely, like, it's not pre-individual, it's not
non-personal, and it sure as fuck isn't a conceptual, right? Like, it's for the same reasons that a signifying
is not just not signifying, right? Um, so, you know, and, uh, and also that over on the next page because
when I was reading it was so funny because this is one of the few moments of reading Deleuze where
I'm having these thoughts as I'm reading it and then he addresses them directly after because I was
reading that, that paragraph, and I was thinking this is Platonism, right? This is a notion of ideality
that is Platonism, and then he went, he's like, it's not play, it's not Platonism, and I was like, oh, cool.
Well, at least I'm thinking along the lines. At least my, my series are somewhat aligned with the series
that he's thinking through here, but I don't even understand why, why use the terminology of ideality
right? Like, why say events are ideal? There is a perfect ideal Protestantism and a real Lutheranism
right? Like, why even, why even? Because the ideational material still operates on the flat plane. Fine, but
but that, but see, that's where to me I like that, at least for me, when he uses the terminology of
I did a little bit of that. What's the, the guy's name? I'd never heard of this philosopher before, this
Austrian guy that I, I looked up and did a little background. Meinong, you know, the Meinong.
Right, and, and my god, it explains so much. Just the Wikipedia entry, that's all I had to do was read
the Wikipedia entry. It's like, oh my god. So the, the thing that I learned, and all I'm doing is repeating
the first paragraph of the Wikipedia entry to you guys right now. That's how in-depth my research is.
But, uh, the thing that Meinong offered was a, a weird version of ontology that apparently got debunked
you know, very shortly thereafter, but in his weird version of ontology, he's like, yeah, there's existence
you know, existence is one sort of mode of being, but then there is subsistence and insistence, and
those things are for, for instance, uh, you wouldn't say that a, uh, a unicorn exists
right, because it's an ideational entity. But as an idea, it relates to the conversation that we, we were
having, like, four or five weeks ago, where we were saying, like, hallucinations are real, they just don't
have the same reality as, you know, a desk, but they're real. I mean, they're not fake, right? They're, they're
really hallucinations, right? So how do you have a terminology to take seriously the reality of a
hallucination, and Meinong's your guy, right? He's like, that's called subsistence. It's a reality, it's
real as a hallucination. You know, it's, it's no less real, it's just, and I think in terms of the movement to
the virtual, you know, later it will be the virtual is real without being actual, so actual there are no
actual unicorns, but they're still real, right? They're real as ideational entities, and, and I love
that thinking because to me that starts taking concepts empirically, right? Like, no, concepts are
real things, right? That doesn't mean that their realities of this is of the same, you know, kind as
the desk, uh, but, but they're equally real. So why go to the terminology of ideal, right? The sort of ideal
real-real relation, ideal-real relation, because at that moment I start to feel like, okay, you are
started. It does seem like it's heading towards saying this is where the, the real reality happens
right? It happens in this, in this area. And again, maybe it's just like earlier Deleuze, I don't know, I
mean, but I just had a, I did at least for me, I had more of a discomfort with the way the terminology
was circulating here than I that I do with other stuff, I guess, and maybe, and again, I think I'm just
just being cranky. I'm not, I'm really not ruling that out, really.
Turning to that language allows him to turn to that Platonic, I mean, that Platonic schemata
and then do the work of reversing it by using the language of the real and the ideal and saying, and
we've got to reverse it, or you've got to put ideas on this on the same plane, the same flight reality
because he does the exact same thing. I mean, this is, you know, the series of the problematic and in the
next page he does the exact same thing with the problematic, which is that the problematic doesn't
govern over something and then get solved or, or subsist and simply create blockages like
problematics are deployed, you know, and, and then create, you know, fields or sets of relations that
allow for how does he put it, um, perfectly objective kinds of being, uh, that you know, even if the problematic
gets solved, like fixed or solved, you know, it still allows for, I mean, it's, it's still enabling
that modality, right? So, but yeah, I mean, that was another place for me where I had that kind of
Like problems don't get solved. That should be the nature of the problem, right? Like the problem should
be the problems encourages responses, and we stop dealing with problems at certain points, but they
don't get solved, you know, or at least that's what I thought he was going to say.
Right, I thought it was going to go down that direction. I took it, I took the salt as a different
like like there are two senses of solved there. Like one is like the the the solving of the problem
writ large so that the problem then goes away. He's saying that never happens, but then there is, you know,
the problematic sets out a kind of life as possible, and then life responds by in some ways solving the
problem by saying all right, given this problematic field, this is the kind of life that comes
out of it, and we're able to, you know, it's able to respond to the problematic, but the solution
is only possible within the uh within the parameters of of the problematic, and so are
the the non-solutions as well. In other words, like within that field you can like like some modes
of life and some parameters of life operate within the solved portion of the thing, and the others don't
you know like think about um think about pan like the problematic of of um pandemic and vaccination
right? And that creates now a modality of life that we are all dealing with, and then the solving of that
problem is to produce vaccines that now now get distributed, and it creates this entire field of
of relationality between you know persons and chemicals and viruses and animals and whatever else, and then you can say like all right, you know, this
you know this distribution model gets this percentage of of the population vaccinated, and you can say
then that we solved it, but that problematic is still operating and it's still creating the
boundaries between the solved life within this problematic and the unsolved the life within
this problematic, but it doesn't but neither solving it or not solving it eradicates the problematic
Yeah, I mean, that's where to me in the case of something like the coronavirus or whatever else we would pick
it's i mean i i just at least in terms of the way that i've always thought of a problem for for delus
like the concept of the problem for delus and foucault it is not a state of affairs and the way that you
just phrased it in that way of thinking means it's a state of affairs and then I thought for instance given
a state of affairs there are multiple problematics um embedded in states of affairs some of which gets
actualized to become their own states of affairs which is pandemic is an example of an actualization of
a series of potential problematics that arise out of you know a virus but the pandemic isn't a
pre-existing state of affairs, right? The like pandemic only right that's what i'm saying but i'm just
saying i'm saying the same thing what i'm not saying is here's a pre-existing state of affairs we
articulate it as a problem and then no no like right you know the problematic of pandemic as a kind of
ideational material you know carves up the world according to a problematic, right? And then within
that world you know there are certain kinds of responses, some of which we'll call solving it and
other ones we'll call not solving the problem, and we can even say like within that more general
problematic there are specific problematics like say like equitable access to vaccination and you know
contending with the um uh the disparity between frontline workers and non-essential whatever else
sure but like those right with that problematic carves up a a space according to its logic and also then
sets out you know the possibility for its own solvency and its own yeah yeah solutions like yeah yeah yeah
I mean like what it means to solve the pandemic I mean I understand you can say pandemic solved it's
imaginable in some future moment that we can say pandemic solved but that's because we've articulated
the problem of this occurring like we we've extracted from the series of potentialities the notion of
pandemic problem death etc we've extracted that and so it's we've made it solvable right but but that's
not the problem to me that's not the problematic right like that that is that is a a labor that's
done so for instance if i return to the terminology of the meinung thing and i say look here are two
series one is the state of affairs and one is the subsistence you know which is existence and one is the
sort of subsistence of ideational components and we look at the relays among them now i can start
thinking about what that means in terms of something like the coronavirus or anything else because you
certainly have like yeah you got a virus that's doing some right like that that's simply the case that
doesn't make it a pandemic that requires labor right it requires conceptual labor on the part of a lot of
people to you know to make this into a pandemic that we would then address and solve and I mean I'm glad
we're doing it this is not that but I I to me thinking of those as a couple of different series
One is the ideational series in that sense, and the other is the actual series. And thinking of the
various relays and connections among them is that then, am I, is what I just said a re-articulation, then
of what you were saying? And if so, okay. And if so, where's sense in that? And why do you need it? I, I think
sense is is the livable world that emerges in the interaction between those series. So sense is the
space between the series and in in that, I mean he describes it that way, right? He says it's the plane of
glass, right? That has on, you know, either side. So okay. So sense is the terrain of what potential
connectivity among series or without which you wouldn't even have series in that regard. Okay.
I can accept that, yeah. I mean, I've been thinking about sense as resource, honestly, like I've been
kind of, you know, and that's I I'm surprised that you're going to my nog and not mentioning the
paradox, the absurd, because that's where it kind of crystallized for me, you know, like what what is the
opposite of pandemic and endemic? Right? Right. So if I were to say endemic, pandemic, right, all of a sudden
we've got a re the re the sense out of out of that and with that is is a resource for new
shit, right? Right. Um, and and it just it seems like that, yeah, that is a field of possibility that is is
becoming. So it'd be like saying, so so the equivalent in terms of common speaking would be when when we
say, I mean, that phrase in a different sense, that's the sense of sense that's relevant, which is to say
not simply a question of a denotation, like a meaning, right? Which which could be unpackable and
sometimes when people say a different sense, that is what they mean, right? They they mean just like
I didn't mean X, I meant Y. Um, but when we say sense, no, we're like valence, right? Right? Right? Like a
different sort of uh disposition or different it's not like it's not a different meaning, it's just a
different. Okay. I mean, that's that's well, this is why I said earlier that I think sense is the way of
him um uh both pointing out and attending to the problem of this the general specific structure event
um uh relationship where like if you create a one-to-one correlationship between um you know
the state of affairs or the world and the and the rules that govern them uh then there's there's um
there's no movement, there's no livable world within there. You only have a whole bunch of of paradoxes
where you know like or you only have errors and and inconsistencies and fallacies um in which to
operate like this is the right mobilization of this word, this is the right um identity like this is the
right referent for this word, this is the right grammar for this word, right? And I think sense for him
allows him to you know imbue both language and speaking with with singularity which is say no no
no, what doesn't matter is you know the referent and and the word. What matters is the sense that the
difference between like the the differential that links those two things together that it creates
you know the singularity that that is that space of livability so and that that's what I mean like
the cup is never ever just the cup. It's not like the word the sound the word cup and
it's uh reference to you know this and other things that sufficiently fit that category. It
is the singularity of of the this of the a liquid of the um um that you know articulates the sense of
this cup in this conversation in this moment in this sort of uh virtual apparatus that we have
which is which is why he goes right which is why he goes to the infinitive like I fully get
when I think about it in terms of the infinitive it totally makes sense to me like
like to to drink. But the other thing is that like I really like the way that he articulates a kind
of relativism here which is that a state of affairs is a relative position to a this a series of
events which has nothing to do with the substance of either of them. So when you were giving the pandemic
example earlier and you're like look there are viruses that circulate around and that's just the case that's
just the case as it is gets demarcated from the position of pandemic, right? But if you were going
to take viruses circulating that could be very well the the problematic that that takes up a different
state of affairs as it's as its object, right? That's right. It's just like I mean in in that case it's just
like well you got to start somewhere in telling the story so where do you start in order to problematize
something else, right? Like so so yeah but I get that of course like any particular thing that you refer
to as your starting point you could always be like well that's not really a starting point that's also
an extraction or a selection
again thinking of it as an extraction makes so much more sense to me, right? Like pulling from
the sort of body without organs again I know I'm reverting to and we said we're going to try not to
do that but reverting to the future vocabulary, you know, pulling from the body without organs to form a
molar entity, you know, and but that molar entity is made up of nothing but the lines of flight
right it's it that's all it's made up of, but it's still something other than the lines of flight
right and so i i just always felt like there was a much more imminent relationship in the later
uh in in the the capitalism books than than here and and i mean i i do believe that i'm being
cranky but i actually think it's in response to this like i you know what i mean like i i don't think
it's simply the day that i'm having right like i actually for whatever reason this reading this to lose
is irritating me more uh than reading most lose so which is neither here nor there and on one level
like you know but there is something about this is it because you feel like
it's it's like an immature version of the later stuff i hope not because i would that would piss
me off because there are times where i'm like it's really cool that he's going into this lewis
this random lewis carroll like i it reminds me of the kafka book so much now i know kafka a hell of
a lot better than i know lewis carroll and so it's super easy for me to follow what and because
there are times in here where he's you know he just makes it's really elusive reference he doesn't
even explain what he's really referring to and i'm like well i don't know what the
fuck that short story is or what happens there where i do know that stuff in kafka and so it's
much easier like sounds there's a place where you were like there's a bunch of sounds apparently in
alice and wonder or one of the you know i'm like i don't know what he's talking about um so you know
you sort of skip those things so maybe that's why maybe it's simply a question of like feeling like
i'm not i don't have a purchase or i don't have hooks in and being irritated by that hooklessness
what you know because we had said we're not going to try to read this through the lens of the leader
and i think that introduces its own problematic which is like now we're creating you know the kind of
authenticity um relationship between his old and and new work where like you know we're going to stick to
this text and the authenticity and you know the purity of this text without and we're going to
somehow bracket you know the language that we're more familiar with with his with his more recent
work and like that seems to me to be like that's increasingly become a futile project to me but it's
equally as distasteful to me um to to say all right now we're just going to read it through
that lens and i wonder if we're being offered a methodology here for thinking of you know what's what's
what's nominally arbitrarily take late and early to lose even though we obviously can't make the
those lines you know clean and now let's think about you know the relationship between the two
as a relay point as a as a catalyst for thinking through this stuff so not immature like you know
jets of singularity is not an immature version of a line of flight um but neither is its own unique
thing that has no connections to the the later articulations of that like i wonder if there's
a way of of forming given what we've read and our own familiars with to lose you know can we form a
single a singular reading of of the logic of sense you know given the relays that we have which i mean
i think he would just say you can't help but do you're doing that anyway i really this kind of goes back
to our question of of associational thinking right like and how we were we were we were all kind of
like oh how do we avoid just doing this idiosyncratically right yeah kind of the question is like
you know what's what's the logic between bringing these two things together um and i i found myself
puzzling over that still with this you know you know series like what yeah this esoteric word is going to
disrupt things but why was it chosen you know what i mean oh i agree i still don't know what the right
i think there at least for me there are a couple of dangers of i mean the reasons that we were talking
about resisting that that you know that way of approaching this is one is here's one tendency you're
just going to judge this as the immature work in relationship to the better work right like so
it's a judgmental ethos then and and and the judgmental ethos is not in and of itself a problem
but it's a problem there because you're not going to learn anything from this book other than i mean
you can't right if you just say if you say you know the the jets of singularities are a proto version
of lines of flight then all you've done is understood Deleuze's relationship to these concepts
and you've done nothing for your own you know and so you you can't learn anything about the
thinking there other than how it developed for this particular person um and so that's that's i think
The beef with it, the hard part, of course, is that especially in a book like this, it's very difficult to
understand, right? Like, at this sort of basic denotative level, I mean, this is, to me, one of the things, and it's
trying to do this. I'm not, you know, but it's hard to understand. So so we're, what we're all doing, I mean,
you know, you pointed to one example and I pointed to another of like these terminology, you know, the
terminology of Meinong or for you the terminology of the absurd. Like, this makes more so this allows me
a hook. This allows me to kind of get in enough that I can start to kind of play, play with it a little
bit. And so we're, we're shifting around looking for, you know, things that will, will help us latch on to
latch on to this to allow us in, uh, but we don't want those things to serve as kind of deadening
you know, effects of like, okay, this is just an immature version or an early version or whatever else
of the thing. So it's, I mean, there's a difficult tension to try to, and and I really feel like I'm coming
out on the bad side because I I think of the passages that rubbed me the wrong way, and I know
I've taught similar kinds of things in the past, and I have students who say those things, and I and I
respond to the students by saying I get why you're having that reaction. Let me just tell you, there's
another possible reaction to have, right? Like, I mean, that's all you can do. So like I get why, for instance,
in this case the word a conceptual is bothering me because I'm like, no, I don't want to think of
this as being a negation of the conceptual, but I also know that it's not, right? Like, I mean, there's
part of me that's like, look, it's not going to do that. He's not actually interested in saying
concepts, although that's one where he kind of is, right? Like, because I mean, I think in terms of
even if we do that evolution of thinking difference in repetition, the concept is the bad guy, right? The
concept is the thing that forms a totality that creates a generality, you know, um, but then you
contrast that with what is philosophy where the concept is like the really interesting thing
composed of lines of flight. So, you know, and here so the a conceptual to me resonates more with
difference in repetition, which everyone thinks is the magnum opus, but I don't really like it. Hasn't
hooked me the same way. I'm much more interested in the kind of later directions. Well, I wonder if this
is in some ways the pedagogy as we're all trying to find our different ways in and he's supplying an
abundance of different labs, right? Whether it's Meinong or Carroll or Poe or the Stoics, right? When you say
too many, but you know, I mean, we're, we're struggling to get a hand on a handle on sense, but like it seems
that's that's exactly what you're trying to produce by creating these serial relationships. Like, here's
the Meinong series. Here's the Deleuze series. And when I when I put them in relationship, then suddenly
it makes sense, right? Like, suddenly it creates a valence through which I can start, you know, making
productive movements forward with this, and I get like I I there there is a space for me to to think and
operate here, and and you know we're all, you know, we're kind of creating a constellation of these
different relation points that is creating the sense. I mean, is the pedagogy of this, is the pedagogy
of reading this book sort of like a training in making sense by putting series and relationships
to each other? In other words, to do what Katie said, like to read associationally? Right? Yeah, that's
why it feels incredibly methodological. I mean, that's a great point, and trust me, I don't I don't read
theory to come, I don't say the word method methodology like ever, like it's not something that interests me,
but for some reason I just kept going there in my reading, especially for for today. It just felt like
very much like here's how to here's how to tease this out, you know, here's how to do it. I mean, I think
you're right, and yeah, it's not a linear, it's not linear in that it's not like a um a set of directives
or a proceed, it's not procedural, right? No, it's also not explicitly reflective, it's not like what I'm
doing by creating series is it's not that, right? Like, you know, that that's the move that I would be more
inclined to make, like the sort of here's why I'm doing, you know, you don't do it in the first series. You
don't even do it in the first three, right? You gotta, you start with number four or maybe number five, which
is basically where he starts it, right? And it's like, okay, but but that's what I I mean, that's my
inclination is to say, okay, the reason that I'm doing this in series, you know, in series five is because
you know, so but he so he doesn't do it in that explicitly reflective of a fashion. He's just like
here's how series work, you know, um, I wonder if the reason I'm hung up on idiosyncrasy, like like not
being too idiosyncratic or not even knowing what that would mean, is maybe because I'm hung up on
thinking about this as potentially procedural when I shouldn't be, you know what I mean? Wait, so so the
like potentially procedural meaning the uh um elimination of the personal is or the subjective
or the personal as in a methodology might give you a linear step-by-step process, right? Do it and
obviously we don't get that here, and perhaps my concern about how to make those choices is me
falling into line with that desire, so it's a tactical move then, on on his part. Obviously it is, you know.
and and in that sense like for me a contrast to the approach here and again one that that i like and
has grown on me i guess is the how to make yourself a body without organs uh chapter in Thousand Plateaus
because it's literally a how to right like how to now it doesn't fucking tell you like the first
sentence is like in any case you already have one or many right like um it's like okay well then i
guess i already did it you know um and but it also examines like masochism and it does examine other
people creating different sort of zones of intensity etc etc so it's not simply the absence but what it
doesn't do is offer it is a how to but it's not a how to as a series of discrete steps it's not that
and so this is like that in that regard it just doesn't say how to you know how to serialize
thinking you know right well i think there's something particularly deceptive about the how to
move or as a reflective move right because i think the way that that reflection if he was running that
reflection thing it wouldn't be parasitic or um supplementary or you know reflective of of the
it's not like there's the primary series and then i can just make the meta move and like suddenly get
above the clouds and then you know resemble what's down here and and then jump back into the main series
it would be its own line of flight right and move would be its own line of flight it's the meta move
would it be its own line of flight that would operate on the same plane as everything else not
transcend it it's not and and yeah and and this is the this is the problem of getting at sense as
well as soon as i start trying to talk about the sense of the sense then i'm i'm already i've already
turned it into something that's not sense i've already denotated it and i'm expressing a different
sense so they're they're like to run the how to as the procedural move like well no oh i i can't tell
you how to run the general operation of setting series into motions because all i'm doing is
setting a different kind of series into motion right now and by taking up you know what appears
to be a meta move as as my denotative object right and right but there's less of an aversion
there's less of an aversion later to the how to right and even though they're not going to actually
give you the usual sort of how to's there's less of an aversion in other words if it's not transcendent
then why shy away from it right like why i mean if if the how to move yeah it looks transcendent but
it's not right like it it looks like it is meta reflexive or metacognitive in casey's use but it's not
so why is it a problem
now how about how about this uh repetition is a series of differential expressions
right so difference is expressed yeah which calcifies into a new entity expressed into a new difference
right and that's that would be difference in its in in itself you know in the in the difference in
repetition book
right so just the sheer connective logic is what governs it right but there's not there's nothing
governing it from the transcendental position and but it's also not random right it is you know the
the parameters of that next thing happening are sort of you know not caused by by it's shaped by the
the expression of the thing that happens before he seems to have a i mean just a kind of returning
interest in the aleatory right the um so maybe random like not not simply random but something that's
utterly contingent purely by chance right not by cause um you know the one event doesn't cause another but
there is this kind of aleatory relationship between one and the next and the next and the next right
like like just by chance like total uh the middle of 56 the problem is determined by singular points
corresponding to the series but the question is determined by an aleatory point corresponding to
the empty space or mobile element the metamorphosis or redistributions of single singularities form a
history each combination and each distribution is an event so it's like a history is a series of
um events right and the connective tissue it seems to me is certainly not cause but
but chance right like um but i think that that chance is is imminent and this is why i resist the language
of random because you know just in the in the common sense way of thinking random is it literally
could be anything that had has no correlation whatsoever what happened beforehand right i think
This is a great sentence to turn to because it connects the aleatory point to the empty square or the
mobile element right, which is a fixed, I mean not fixed, but it is a structural part of the series itself, is
that, you know, the expression of of sense is the expression of the empty is the of the empty square
the thing that provides a parameter for something but isn't necessarily filled, you know, the the um, the
mobile element which is, you know, the the thing without a place right, the place without the thing and the
thing without the place and so the aleatory moment, like the dice throw in in that moment, or what gets
returned in the expression of that difference is is is singularly connected to um, you know, to the
thing that gets expressed. It's not a tabula rosa so it's necessity, right? There's a but there's a necessity.
I mean, that that's, I mean, I'm thinking in terms of the Nietzsche book which that's why I said it gets
returned there, right? That's after, right, right, um, because in that that's the case where he, I mean, I like
for instance in that maybe I just can't understand this very simply right like I just don't I just don't
I mean, I hear you, I hear you Nathaniel, and like right like I agree with with why not random, right? Because
one problematic field right has a elements that make it up and those are the ones that would then fold
in into the next, but in the next one where it is about games and and chance he's interested in this game
this ideal game that has no um, preset uh limit, right? No no no boundaries, right? There there would be no
edges like there is no roulette wheel, it's it's just like pure um, open. This is really hard for me to
to think through because I don't think I don't think that those two things are opposed to each other
right? I don't think that it's there that there is a necessary opposition between saying that the
singularity of the expression of assent is in its very constitution, you know, I don't think that there's a
a difference between saying that there is a specific or not a specificity but a singularity of or of a
differential expression and saying then that there is sort of like a constraint or a a preset field in
which that it has to fall within, right? Because that preset field would seem to be a transcendent imposition
by a general rule whereas it seems like the the differential expression would be the expression of an entire
world itself. So let me let me try this because this is where and maybe it's just because I spent time
on the dice throw concept but it makes so much more sense to me where you say like the dice returning
to earth or you know the two moments the dice throw, throwing the dice, dice returning to earth, right?
first is the moment of chance, second is the moment of necessity, um, but in fact it's the dice returning to
earth that are the combination of chance and necessity and so it's in their combination of chance and necessity
because what's necessary to be a good player, right, is is not to win, right, not to try to win or not to
organize it according to a logic or a plan in which you get double sixes or whatever else that what's
what's important for him and what he's trying to emphasize in that this is Nietzsche's version, right?
like what he's emphasizing in his take on Nietzsche is the necessity of the necessity of engaging chance
of a subsequent dice throw, right, like uh, and that we as humans always try to reduce chance through
probability, right? That's our mo, right? Is reducing chance through probability, um, but what's interesting
to me when I think about this is that when the dice throw returns it's the you know, um, it doesn't
cause the next dice throw it's not causal but it's necessary, right? Like the the necessity of a subsequent
a subsequent dice throw is not causally related but still necessary. Well this is why I think that the
the linkages between the elements of a series is nothing more than the dice throw the eternal return
or the differential expression but it's an it's in the set but but the relationship is not causal
it's not causal but it's also not just fucking anything exactly, you know, it's a relationship of necessity in
that case, right? Like I mean he uses explicitly the terminology, it's like there is a necessity of you
you got to do something when the dice is like even if you walk away from the game it doesn't you got
to do something. Here's another way of saying it and and here's another way of saying it is that random
isn't um, radical enough, right? Random the the notion of the random doesn't go far enough because the
random would say like you know, within this field of possibilities any possible event could return and there's
no rhyme or reason why it would be this or that right? But the but the different but differential
expression or the return the casting of the die and the return of the die you know, it it isn't
it isn't returning a possibility within a field of possibilities it is changing the parameters of
the field of possibilities itself. That's what I said it's it's it's the creation of of the whole new
world and that's why like the the aleatory the um, the the moment of chance there is beyond even the
Spectrum of the random. I thought you were saying the other direction of that, Nathaniel.
I thought so, so I agree with what you just said. That's my sense of how that works, right, with the aleatory.
Like it's the possibility of something totally, um, not yet, uh, conceived of, right? Not, not in this, like
latent set of potentialities which might come to fruition, but like something that we don't even we
haven't even encountered yet, right? Anything literally inconceivable, right? Go Princess Bride.
This is the kind of paradox that I want to hold on to is that even though this goes beyond
you know, the possibility of the random, it is still, I mean, conditioned by is probably not the right
word, or informed by the expression of the thing that is expressing, right? In other words, you know, the
expression of one series and the expression of the other thing, you know, there's not like an equal
chance that they're going to return the exact same thing, right? It is the idiosyncrasy, it is the
singularity of the thing that expressed that is going to inform the world that gets returned, but
whatever world that is returned is going to rewrite the entire field of possibilities, and hence like
what you know random could even look like within that field of possibilities. Let me, this is a slight
tweak on that, but there's a how did you guys understand in when two series are related one is always
excessive and one is always lacking, right? That that's necessary condition for the interrelation uh of two
series, and that just sort of it surprised me, you know, for obvious reasons, right? Like
Anti-Oedipus is entirely written against the concept of of both excess and lack because excess is just
another version of lack, um, so so what does it mean? I mean he uses the example of the signified and signified
there, right? Where the signifier is the one that's excessive and the signified is the one that's
lacking because that's the sort of state of affairs or the conceptual totality, but unlike the version of
of lack and and excess that he that has a problem with Anti-Oedipus is that there's no remainder here.
There are unequal sides of of the whole I think he describes it as. And this goes back to the earlier series
where I mean either the the empty signifier, the empty square that is the expression of of sense
that is sense itself, and and the denotation is the um is the other one though the the the the thing
without the place, right? And this is why this that is the necessity of the return of the dice throw
to me is that explain say that explain that the the necessity of the I love I love I I thought this was
going to happen by the way earlier because I was like I know you love this book in particular and I've always
had kind of a and I'm like this is going to be fun because you're going to be the teacher.
It's so great I love it I love it like I want it I explain that man.
Um, all right, so go back to the the series. I'm gonna be a shitty student to be clear.
That's okay. That's before you thought before you start, Nathaniel, where are you? Are is this is this in the
Leucan one? I'm all yeah that was the that's the signifier the Levi-Strauss one. Levi-Strauss, right?
Right now it's on page 49. Yeah, yeah. So two two series being given signified and signified there's
a natural excess of the signifying series and a natural lack of the signified there's a floating
signifier this is on the bottom of the last paragraph from 49 there is a floating signifier which is the
servitude of all finite thought but also the promise of all art and uh we would like to add that is the
promise of all revolutions then there is on the other side the floated floated signified given
by the signifier without being therefore known without being therefore assigned or or realized
that's where you get the Levi-Strauss proposed to interpret this as gadget or whatever something
illiquid but also mana yeah he uses mana minimal conditions for structure in general on the next page
at least two heterogeneous series one of which is so-called signifying the other is signified
each of these is constituted by terms which exist only through the relations they maintain
with one another so in other words they don't stand there's no single series right series are all
only exist in relation um so these relations are rather to the values that there correspond very
particular events that are singularities which are assignable within the structure so these are the
means of relation among the different series I take that so um so tell me again about the empty square
because the empty square one empty square in place empty place and places occupant this is um in the
the sixth series we're talking about the sheep's shop uh 41 41 as in a game we participate in the
combination of the empty space and the perpetual displacement of a piece where Alice discovers the empty shell
yeah so this is in the middle of the the first unfinished paragraph that spills over from 40 on 41
Um, we're like uh, they are simultaneous without ever being equal since the entity has two sides, one of
which is always absent from the other. It behooves it therefore to be in access to the one series
which it constitutes as signifying and lacking in the other which it constitutes as signified
split apart, incomplete by nature or in relation to itself. A little bit further down for that which is
in excess uh in one case is nothing but an extremely extremely mobile empty place and that which is
lacking in another case is rapidly move as a rapidly moving object, an occupant without a place, always
supernumerary and displaced. I mean, to me, he's talking about, I mean, he's getting at the logic of becoming
here and not thinking about a logic of negation which I mean, I know he uses the language of lack and
excess but I I just don't think that those. Well, it almost, it almost seems, and I agree with you, I don't
think it's in the same sense, right? But but I also I mean, it does seem to me there that what he's after
here is saying um first of all the two series are never they're always in relation and they're never
unified as distinct series that they're always in relation like the idea that one contains this sort
of space without uh an occupant and the other has an occupant without a space like they're related to
each other, right? Like there is a relationship there as yet to be determined, right? Like it's not you
know it's it's not given, right? So it's not um so it's only excessive or lacking in in in response to
some sort of what we would call the state of affairs or something that's more relatively established, right?
Like that's that's more stabilized. So it's always these series are always so you've got two series
in relation but they're not really two series because it's you know they're not two distinct
things that are then in relationship to one another, right? So you're trying to me I think that is like
he's going after relationality being primary without saying relationality is primary, you know, that strikes me as
the sense of what he's after there. Well to me series is nothing more than relationality with movement
right? So then the question then would be what's the difference between a series and two series in
relation? Nothing, because a series is always composed of two series in relation and then either one of those
series is composed of other two series in relationship. We'll just we'll just keep in mind that a structure
is a is two series in relation to each other, right? Right. Well that's the infinite regress problem.
Right, that's in other words like when you try to get at the sense you're always moving to another
place you're always creating a different series in attempting to get to the sense of something
because anytime you're taking up an object as denotation you're expressing a new sense
which would be the empty square. Does that make sense? No uh it is creating it is creating that a sense of
something that doesn't yet exist that has not yet been denoted. Okay, yeah, that's fine. So I can so in
other words like I I take you know I I say something it and it refers to something else right it takes up the
sense of that something else and and um as its object but in doing so it expresses its own sense, right? This
is just again the problem of the infinite regress and so it's expressed and it expresses its own empty
signifier which then gets taken up as a this is the the alchemy of it as I the way I understand it is
that that empty square gets taken up as an object without a place by the next right? Okay, series
right and the necessity of the thing is is that I mean this is this is why I said this
the the the linkages between the series is the return of the of the dice throw or is the return
of the dice, right? It's like that this is why the return of the dice is necessary because there is this
disequilibrium there is this warping the warping of becoming is like this. There is um and I also think
this is why he talks about it in terms of a lack although again not in that Lacanian sense is that
there is this thing without a home and I'm going to give it a home by taking it up as an object I'm
going to denotate it, give it a home, right? But I can't give this thing a home without creating a new
orphan, right? Right, so I mean, I get that I get that. Okay, so in that in that in that way like the diagram
like you'd have the diagram of the two series and their interrelations but even within one series
itself that's already a microscopic or macroscopic version of another couple of series in relation to
one another. Add in tonight are you serious? Yeah, is that Lee protesters he says just broke into the
Capitol. It's been going on for an hour. Wait, what? It's the U.S. Capitol, tear gas, gunshots, whoa, holy
it's a little minute mini coup. People broke in. They had to evacuate Mike Pence and all them. Are they
Trump protesters or that's the Trump protesters? Yeah, that's the that they're having that protest right
now. Yeah, we won't get over the uh floor of the senate. There's a picture of a guy in Pence's seat
With a crump flag, oh my god, yeah, House Senate recess as pro-trump mob breaches capital and there's a
a lot of options that don't tread on me, yeah, there's gonna be some wine he said, I think there's gonna
be some treading, yeah, maybe I'll attribute my crankiness to anticipation of those events
We'll see you next time.